Yeah.
>> My second question, not as serious. It's
just uh something I'm curious about.
>> Yes.
>> In Genesis
uh 32
24-32, Jacob's challenge
>> when he becomes Israel.
>> Yeah. He wrestles a man whom he says,
"God, I've seen God face to face. My
life was spared."
>> I do not understand this. Is he
wrestling
God who wins? He has power over God and
man.
>> Yes, he wrestles God.
>> Doesn't make any sense to me.
>> The text says he wrestled God. The man
was God. How do you know? Because in
Genesis 32:30, he called the place
pineal. For I have seen God face to
face, yet my life was spared. So, it
tells you it's God. And then Hosea
12:25, it says it was the angel of God
who's God. So, but why would that be a
problem? God appeared as a man. He
wrestled God and he won. He won.
>> It's not a problem. I'm just curious and
I knew you would answer the question.
>> Yeah, but what's troubling you? Because
it doesn't make sense to you. So,
there's a problem if it doesn't make
sense to you.
[snorts]
>> I can't even I don't even know. I can't
even make enough sense out of it to tell
you what my problem is with it.
[laughter]
>> Your problem, dude, is how can a man
defeat God? Come on, dude.
>> Thank you. Actually, yes. Thank you.
That's a great way to put it. How can a
man be stronger than God? How can he
have power over God and man and be and
then become Israel the the promise of
God?
>> You didn't read it carefully, brother.
When the man touched Jacob's socket,
Jacob limped the rest of his life,
right?
>> Yes.
>> So, what does that tell you about the
power of the man? If just by one touch
of his hip socket, he wrenched his
socket out of place where now he became
somewhat crippled and he had to walk
with a limp the rest of his life.
>> Yeah. Baby K.
>> Can you imagine what the man would have
done to him if he just snapped his neck?
>> Very powerful.
>> So [snorts] what does that tell you
then?
That
>> God was going easy on him.
>> You got it. Like when you wrestle with a
child,
>> he was playing
>> but at the same time trying to teach.
>> You better believe it. He's wrestling
with him and putting enough effort to
make him Jacob to exert effort and to
teach him. You must endure to the end if
you want to be blessed. Giving up is not
the way to go to receive the blessing.
>> But fighting but fighting the truth and
God will leave you with a limp.
Well, it it's not so much leave you with
a limp as it is that you must enter the
kingdom through many tribulations.
Entering the kingdom,
Acts 14:22
entails a life of hardship and suffering
and sacrifice. So God is teaching Jacob
that if you want to receive the blessing
and inherit the blessing and reign with
God, then you're going to have to
undergo many trials and tribulations and
experience tremendous suffering and much
sacrifice and you're going to have to
endure. Otherwise, you'll never receive
the blessing.
>> Amen.
>> Amen. That makes a lot more sense now.
And so that's why Jacob, when he's told,
"Let me go." He says, "I won't. I'm
going to rustle you and force you to
bless me." Now, you learn the lesson.
Because up until that point, had you
read the narrative carefully? Jacob's
life is characterized by running from
his problems and using connivory and
trickery and deceit in order to get what
he wants. But it always comes at a price
because he's always running for his
life.
And then he's forced to face his
problems.
>> Yes. This is not how you're going to be
blessed if you try to connive and
deceit. Because the name Yakov can mean
deceiver, suppler, sceiver, a conniver.
If you're always conniving and you're
always using deceit and you're always
plotting to try to get ahead, you won't.
That's why you're always on the run
because your life is in peril because it
ends up backfiring against you. That's
not how you're going to get the
blessing. Face your problems, overcome
your pro problems, trust God is with
you, and endure until you receive the
blessing. That was the object lesson.
>> Amen.
>> That was it. And so that's why he says,
"Your name will no longer be Jacob."
Meaning your name, which means suppler,
someone who seeks to supplant by
trickery, right? Will no longer be
definitional of who you are. You will no
longer be known as a suppler, a
deceiver. You're going to be known as a
prince with God because Israel, it even
comes from the root s, which means
prince. Why?
>> Because you finally faced your trials
and tribulations. You wrestled with God
and man, meaning me, God, who appeared
as man, and you wouldn't let me go, and
you insisted that I bless you. And
because you persisted, I honored your
persistence because the effectual
fervent prayer of righteous man avails
much.
Now you're blessed. And if you notice,
from that moment on, Jacob's character
does a 180. From that moment on in the
narrative, he's no longer portrayed as
conniving, deceiving, right, or running.
He's courageous and straightforward
>> from that moment on because now he
learned.
>> Amen. That's that's a big lesson I
learned in my life recently. And and
learning that right now just makes me
want to cry.
>> Amen. And that was Jesus appearing to
him because he's angel of the Lord.
That's why when Pharaoh asked Jose
Jacob, look what he asked him. Genesis
47 8-9. When Pharaoh asked Jacob and
Pharaoh said to Jacob, "How many are the
days of the years of your life?" So
Jacob said to Pharaoh, "The days of the
years of my souljouring are 130. I've
been,
you know, on this earth 130 years.
They've been few and evil have been the
days of the years of my life, and they
have not attained to the days of the
years of that my fathers live during the
days of their sojouring." You see what
he said? 130 years old and those short
years have been nothing but evil all my
life.
So this tells you Christianity is not a
walk in the park. And this tells you
either you do it God's way or you do it
your way. And it's going to be harder to
do it your way because it's even hard to
do it God's way. But at least if you do
it God's way, you'll be protected.
So this is Christianity, a life that
will be hard,
that will be painful,
and that will be depressing
and sad. But if you endure,
God will give you grace and strength to
endure it until you finish the race and
enter your rest.
Because understand one of the greatest
pains that Jacob experienced. He thought
his 17-year-old son Joseph, the first
son from the wife he loved, Rachel,
because remember the other children were
from Leah and the maid servants. Leah
was the older sister whom he didn't
love. He loved the younger sister. But
God deliberately opened the womb of Leah
before Rachel so that Jacob would not
discriminate against Leah. but love her
the same.
Rachel gave birth to Joseph, her first
son. He was son number 11. And if you
read Genesis
chapter 37, read it. You'll see that the
older brothers realized Jacob loved
Joseph more than them.
Genesis 37.
And they were jealous of him and envious
of him and despised him. Now watch how
God
humbles Joseph, humbles Jacob and also
makes Jacob cling to Leah. Rachel, his
favorite life wife, died when she gave
birth to his 12 son, Benjamin. Genesis
35, she died. She died giving birth to
Benjamin, his last son, and Joseph's
fullblooded brother.
Joseph and Benjamin are from the same
mother.
Because Joseph was the first son of
Rachel, they knew, you'll see it,
they're jealous of him all throughout
that
Jacob
loved Joseph in a special way. What do
you guys learn about these stories? I
want you guys to see the Bible depicts
the characters and the narrative as real
people because they are warts and all
doesn't sugarcoat or cover up their sins
and imperfections. And you see they were
dysfunctional. What do I mean? For a
parent to show favoritism
creates [snorts] hatred and animosity in
the family. Which is why in Genesis 37,
you read the narrative, the brothers
hate Joseph because they see he's a
spoiled brat that Jacob loves and
prefers.
But backtrack.
Jacob and Esau were twins. If you go and
read,
if you start reading from Genesis 26
and all the way to 28, you're going to
notice Isaac preferred Esau and yet
Rebecca preferred Jacob. Again, a sign
of dysfunctionality.
Isaac Esau because he's a hunter as you
destroy our ears with your microphone
turning pages. And yet Rebecca preferred
Jacob. And Rebecca even conied with
Jacob because she loved him more to
deceive Isaac in his old age because of
his poor sight and thinking Jacob was
Essa to bless him. So she coned with him
to deceive her husband. Here again a
sign of dysfunctionality.
And what the Bible shows you is when you
pick favorites among your children,
you're going to create an environment
where siblings will despise one another.
There'll be sibling rivalry. And it's
your fault.
>> Are you with me there? [snorts]
>> Yes, sir.
>> Yeah, because you're turning the pages
by your microphone and you're blowing
our eardrums.
>> I'm sorry. I'm sorry. I'll put it down.
>> All right. You see what I'm getting at?
>> Yeah. [clears throat] I uh I was trying
to save the page.
>> Yeah, just write it. You can go back and
rewatch it. So, what am I getting at?
the pain of Jacob. When in Genesis 37,
they sold Joseph into slavery to the
Medionites, Israelites, who then sold
him to potterer. They took his coat of
many colors which his father gave him,
killed an animal, spread the blood of
the animal on it in order to deceive
Jacob into thinking Joseph had been
mauled by an animal. When Jacob
discovered that Joseph was alive, Joseph
was already in his 40s.
That means for over 20 years,
Jacob thought his son was died. And for
over 20 years, he lived in misery and
depression, mourning his son, only to
see a son, a grown man, second only to
Pharaoh, the savior of the earth, with
two sons, Ephraim and Manessa. And yet,
he lost all those years. He didn't have
Joseph from 17 all the way into Joseph's
40s. See, this is the cost. This is the
price we pay for living in a fallen
world, a selfish world, an evil world, a
sinful world.
This is why
he said,
"Few and evil have been the days and
years of my life. I've lived in constant
misery."
All right. Right. So, you got it now,
brother.
>> Uh, point of clarification.
The point is the point you're trying to
make is that evil
makes people
>> No, that's not the point I'm making.
>> It It takes It takes joy away from
people. It takes time and joy away from
people.
>> Christian life is a life of pain and
suffering and trials and tribulations
and misery and you have to endure it.
That's the point.
Okay, brother.
>> Yes, sir.
>> All right, brother. Let me go on Ryan
and I got a few more and then we're
going to go. Thank you, brother. You're
good, man.
>> Thank you so much. Have a good night.
>> You, too.